we begin with a very terrible story it
involves a plane crash in Africa
Ethiopian Airlines is now grounded the
rest of its brand-new Boeing 737 max
eight Jets while it investigates
Sunday's crash that killed 157 people
flight 302 tuner OB Kenya went down
minutes after takeoff from Ethiopia
Ethiopia's capital addis ababa the
victims came from 35 different countries
and eight of them are American the
planes black boxes have been found but
the cause of the crash is still unknown
it's the second accident in five months
involving a Boeing Max 8 jet
Debora patta is in is at Jomo Kenyatta
International Airport in Nairobi where
the plane was supposed to land
good morning many of the people aboard
Ethiopian Airlines flight 302 were
heading here to Nairobi to attend the
United Nations conference the US has
sent its condolences to all the families
of those on board the plane piles of
mangled debris lie scattered around the
crash site strewn amongst the wreckage
items of clothing and personal
belongings a jarring reminder of just
how many lives were lost
the arrival board simply read flight
delayed at Nairobi's International
Airport yesterday while back in Ethiopia
reality began to sink in for frantic
relatives after the news was announced
the Ethiopian Airlines CEO faced the
public we are very very saddened flight
302 took off at 838 local time from
Ethiopia's Bolle International Airport
in Addis Ababa heading for Nairobi
seconds later the pilot made a distress
call wanting to turn back then of just
six minutes into the flight all contact
was lost and the plane crashed in debris
site 31 miles south of the capital an
eyewitness described seeing the plane go
down
it came directly from the sky downwards
he said and we heard a huge explosion
the jet was a new Boeing 737 max eight
that the airline had recently purchased
at the end of last year on the plane
35 nationalities from around the world
so many of those people had dedicated
their lives to helping others the United
Nations has been hard hit by the crash
losing 19 staff members from people
providing safety for Refugees to those
fighting world hunger the flight
manifest reads like a list of the very
best of humanity the CBS this morning
Debora patta Nairobi Kenya
such a terrible story